you're going to tell us everything you
know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier
i on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me
no bodyguarding no
to protect this homicidal nut bags wife
what is he doing here i said can anyone
buy michael rice i believe it's
pronounced
thank you in four days
all of you loved was burned they're
planning a full-scale cyber attack do
not
screw this up but we are definitely
going to screw this up
i promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
on i got it
no it's fine you guys just you guys have
had him maybe feather the break a bit
i need you to protect us we're trying to
have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me
i'm unlicensed i'm unlicensed that's
terrible
louder i'm unlicensed and i don't give
up
we need guns we need boats
we need them are you ready to get your
free con
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong
now let's go do what we do and blow some
things up
i would make a great mother don't you
think i think you're good
thank you it must be your powerful
asexuality that makes you such a good
listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
[Music]
you